so today we're going to talk about a few
miracles of learning in the context of
the theme that we're developing here in
the class we started off with discussion
of some basic methods talked about
nearest neighbors and we talked about
identification trees and those are kind
of basic things that have been around
for a long time still useful still the
right things to do when you're faced
with a learning problem and you're not
sure what method to try then we went on
to talk about some naive biological
mimicry we talked about neural nets and
we talked about genetic algorithms and
you look at those things you think
reflect back on what we talked about and
how to say to yourself are these
nugatory ideas perhaps piss terrines or
are they super oratory ideas that
deserve to be center stage anybody doing
those words me a piss train well mister
een is a Spanish coin that was so small
it was a little worth these ideas these
ideas like neural nets genetic
algorithms
I guess classify them as pitch terrines
because getting them do something is
rather like getting a dog to walk on its
hind legs you can make it happen but
they never do it very well and you have
to think it took a lot of trickery or
training to make it happen so not too
not too personally a high on those ideas
but we teach it to you anyway because of
course we're we only editorialized part
of the time and part of the time we like
to cover what's in the field today yeah
we're starting a couple of
discussions of mechanisms or ideas or
things to know about that are quite
different because now we're going to
focus on the problem rather than the
mechanism and then a little later on
we're going to talk about deep theory fo
iOS for its own sake but this week I
want to talk about mechanisms that that
were devised I want to talk about
research that was done let me not say
mechanisms let me say research that was
done to to to attempt an account of some
of the things that we humans do well
sometimes without even knowing that we
do it now Krishna here tells me his
first language was Telugu Telugu I once
had another student whose first language
was Telugu I said to him that must be
one of those obscure Indian languages
and he said yes it's spoken by 56
million people French is spoken by 52 so
he's going to be our experimental
subject Krishna if I PluralEyes words
you know what it means to pluralize a
word so if I say for example horse then
if I ask you for the plural say horses
so if I say dog what's the pearl no no
in English
and what about cat and he got it right
not a miracle
when did you start speaking English
sorry but he still got it right and he
never learned that he's actually
pluralizing those words differently but
he is so when you PluralEyes dog what's
the sound that comes after
that's a Z sound
dogs you stick your fingers up here you
can feel your vocal cords vibrating just
take a piece of paper in front of your
mouth you'll see it vibrate
but when you say cats the pluralizing
sound is like that no vocalizing no no
vibration of the vocal course and Oh
Krishna here learned that rule as did
all of the other non-native speakers of
English effortlessly and without
noticing it you learned it they always
get it right how can that possibly be
well by the end of the hour you'll know
how that might be and you'll experience
a case study and how questions of that
sort can be approached with a sort of
engineering point of view you can say
what if God were an engineer or
alternately what if I were God and I am
an engineer think about how it might
happen that way so we want to understand
how it might be that the machine could
learn rules like that phonological rules
not just that one but all the
phonological rules you'd acquire and of
course on phonology that part of
speaking that deals with those syllabic
and subsonic sounds the phones of the
language so when you up and Sussman
undertook to solve this engineering
problem both being dedicated engineers
the first thing they did was learn the
science so they went to sit at the foot
of Moore's Holly who would develop
largely responsible for the development
of theories of so-called distinctive
features and here's how that works you
start off with a person who wants to say
something
and out that pushed his mouth from some
sort of acoustic pressure wave and if I
say hello George and you say hello
George everybody will understand that we
said the same thing but that acoustic
waveform won't look anything
be very different for all of us so it's
a miracle that the that this that words
can be understood in any case it goes
into an ear and it's processed and out
comes a sequence of distinctive feature
vectors a distinctive feature is a
binary variable like is this is the is
the phone voiced or not that is to say
are your vocal cords vibrating when you
say it if so then that's plus voiced if
not it's - voiced so according to the
original distinctive feature theory and
consistent with most of the theories
that have been derived since the
original one there are on the order of
14 of these distinctive features that
determine which phone you're saying so
if you say yeah that's one combination
of these binary features if you say
that's another combination of these
binary features 14 of them so how many
how many sounds does that mean that in
principle there could be in a language
and what's 2 to the 14th Sebastian well
I ought to be about 16,000 don't you
think two of the 10 there's a thousand
two to the fourth or 16 so they're about
16,000 possible combination but no
language on earth has more than a
hundred phones that's strange isn't it
because some of those traces are
probably excluded on physical grounds
but most of them are not so we could
have a lot more phones in our language
than we actually do English has about 40
so the sequence of distinctive features
could be viewed as then producing
meaning
after perhaps a long series of
operations but in the end those
operations feed back in here because
many of the distinctive features are
actually hallucinating we think we heard
them but they're not there or they're
there or they're not even in the
acoustic wave form they're there for the
convenience of the phone ologist who
make rules out of them
it's a remarkable how much how much of
this feedback there is an even injection
from other modalities many of you may
have heard about the McGurk effect
here's how the McGurk effect works look
at me while I say God okay I said GA now
how about ba ba ba ba okay I said Bob
like a sheep but if I take the sound I
make when I say baa and play it while
I'm well you're taking a video of me
saying God what do you think you're here
you don't here Bob some people report
that they hear a da sound like da when I
look at it I don't I can't make any
sense out of it it looks like the
there's a disconnection between the
speech and the video but it does not
sound like Bob but if I shut my eyes and
say ba ba it's absolutely clear that is
BA so what you see has a large influence
on what you what you hear it's also
interesting although a side issue it's
also interesting to note that it's very
difficult to pronounce things correctly
if you don't see the speaker so many
people wonder when they learn foreign
languages why they can't speak like a
native and the answer is that are not
watching the mouths of the speaker I was
talking to a German friend once and said
you know I just can't say that damned
umlauts right and he said oh the trouble
with you Americans is you don't realize
that American cows say Moo
but German cows say Moo and of course I
got it instantly because I could see
that the umlaut sounds are produced with
protruding lips which we don't have any
we don't have any sounds of English that
requirement oh but back to back to what
we know from the phonologists about all
this stuff we talked to Morris Hawley he
will tell you that over here I'd like to
think of it as a marionette there are
five pieces of meat down here and the
combination of distinctive features that
you're trying to utter are like the
control of a marionette on those five
pieces of meat so if you want to say an
a sound
the marionette control goes into a
position that produces that combination
so let's see what is that distinctive
feature sequence look like for a typical
word well here's a word a pea and apples
and we can talk about what distinctive
features are arrayed in that particular
combination of phones so one of the
features that they like to talk about is
syllabic that roughly means can that
sound form that the sort of core of a
syllable and the answer is a can that
these can't so it's plus minus minus
minus add out here in other ways you'll
run into the voiced feature and for the
voiced feature well we can we can do the
experiment ourselves ah sounds like his
voice to me huh no that's not voiced Oh
yep we already said that was voiced so
that's the combination you see when you
utter apples for the voice feature then
another one is the continuent one that
roughly says is your vocal apparatus
open is there any is there no
obstruction
and so A+ [ __ ] that's constricted little
open this is open so that one happens to
run right along with voice in that
particular word oh and they're 14
altogether but let me just write down
one more the destroyed at one that says
do you use your tongue to form a little
jet of air so you don't on a PA blue
that you do on Z so that gets a plus so
that's a glimpse through a soda straw of
what it would be like to represent the
word apples and as a set of distinctive
features all arranged their sequence so
it's a matrix of features it's so going
down and the columns we have our
distinctive features and going across we
have time so first thing assessment and
and yet did in their effort to
understand how phonological rules can be
learned is to design a machine that
would interpret words and sounds and
things that you see so as to produce the
sounds of the language so they imagined
the following kind of machine the
machine has some kind of mystery
apparatus over here that looks out into
the world and sees what's there
so I'm looking out of the world and I
see two apples so what this machine
might do then is at some point decide
that there are two apples out there then
thinking in terms of these guys as
computer engineers they think in terms
of a set of registers that hold values
for concepts like noun and verb
and plural and we've not done anything
with a machine yet we provided no input
so those so those registers are all
empty that up in here we have a set of
words and there are all kinds of words
Apple is one of them and those those
words that there know about how the
concept is rendered is a set of as a
sequence of phones that is a sequence of
distinct features then over here most
importantly they have a set of
constraints so we'll talk about a
particular constraint the plural
constraint for plural constraint number
one and it's going to reach around and
connect itself to some other parts of
the machine finally there's a buffer of
phones to be uttered and they're gonna
flow out this way to the speaker's mouth
and get translated into a acoustic wave
form so that's a those are the elements
of the machine now how are the how are
the elements are connected together
well the
the words are connected of course into
the buffer that is used to generate the
sound over here on the far left the
plural register is connected to what you
see in the world what you see in the
world is connected not only to the
plural register but to all of the
objects in the word repertoire this
plural constraint here deserves extra
attention because it's going to be
desirous of actuate in itself in the
event that the thing observed in the
world is floral there are lots of them
so that's the it's going to be connected
then to the plural port there's going to
be a Z sound port down here connecting
to that final element in the buffer and
finally over here is going to be a plus
voiced port which is going to be
connected to the second phoneme of the
sequence that's how the machine is going
to be claimed to be arranged and of
course this is just one of many
constraints but it's a constraint that
has a very peculiar property information
can flow through it in multiple ways so
we think in most programs as having an
input and an output but I've tried to be
careful to draw circles here instead of
arrows because these are these are ports
and information can flow in any
direction along them what I want to do
now is just show you how this machine
would react if I suddenly present it
with a pair of apples like so so the
assumption is that the vision apparatus
comes in and produces the notion the
concept of two apples so
that has happened that's a operation
number one then information flows from
that
meaning register up here to the Apple
word
so that's part of stage number two
another part of stage number two is
information flows along this wire and
marks that is plus plural so operation
number one is the activity the vision
system activity number two there's the
flow of information from that vision
system into the word lexicon and into
this plural register so far so good
here's activity number three this is
word is also connected to the registers
and information flows along those wires
so as to indicate that it's a noun but
not a verb that's part of part number
three at the same time part number three
the information flows down this wire and
writes a P L into those elements of the
buffer now this constraint up here this
box says well I can now see some stuff
in that buffer that wasn't there before
so it says so I see enough stuff on my
ports to get excited about expressing
values on other ports well let's see
what does it got it's got the elements
from this buffer also up here in step
three
flow the plural thing so it knows that
the word is plural so it says is this
voiced P is tough that's not voiced is
this a Z sound no that's not a Z sound
so it sees what it likes on only one of
its three ports so it says I'm not going
to do anything I'm out of order combo
in this particular combat so far so good
what happens next what happens next is
that some time passes and the elements
of the buffer flow to the left toward
the speaker's mouth so we get an A P L
same as we had before but shifted over
now what happens now what happens is
that the P or the L is now in the
penultimate position so information
flows up here item number four oh I
guess that's item number five item
number four is the leftward flow of the
word so in phase number five the P is
witnessed by this constraint P is well
sorry L is witnessed by this constraint
we've moved it over one L is el Azul L
is voiced so we have some flow up here
like that that's number five now we have
voiced and we have plural and we have
nothing here so the there's a great
desire of this buffer to have something
written into it so now there's a flow
down in there of Z as item number six so
that's how the machine would work in
expressing the idea that there are
apples in the field of view
real apples not plastic imitations so
that's how the machine works but all
those connections are reversible so if I
hear apples now I get the machine
running backwards and my visual
apparatus can imagine that there are
apples out there that's how it works
that's just by way of background the
machine that they could see for using
the phonological rules once they're
learned all the phonological rules are
expressed in these constraints but since
these constraints are such that
information can flow in any direction
they deserve to be called propagators
and then the good old days when everyone
took six double-o one they learn about
propagators as a kind of architecture
for building complex systems any event
there's an assessment yet machine and
now comes the big question how do you
how do you learn rules like that well
what we need is we need some positive
examples and some negative examples
and for the simple classroom example
I've chosen the same challenge that I
presented it to Krishna we're gonna have
cats and dogs so we got a look at the
distinctive features that are associated
with those words
syllabic voiced continuing and strident
just four of the 14 features that are
associated with each of the sounds of
those words could you close the laptop
please so just just one of the
distinctive features that are arrayed of
those words by way of illustration so
here we have k80 see phonetically
spelled and if we work that out let's
see what is syllabic that's not that is
that is that's not voiced cut nope ah
yep T nope
z yes I can't be right cats i misspelled
it has cats as a hissing sound but
there's no voicing so that's not a Z
sound it's an S sound that's not a plus
voiced it's - voiced continue it
let's see is my mouth open when I say
que no ah yes t no s yes and strident -
minus - plus it's only with a Z with the
S sound that I have that kind of just
forming with my tongue now we can look
at dogs
and now we have the Z sound as the
pluralization we know that because when
we say it dogs yep Erik comes out as a
as a yeah well you're only got to look
at the last two columns because
everything only ones that are going to
matter to us so that's plus and that's -
good good good good
that's up plus and that's plus they're
both voiced is that right dog good good
is G sound voice no I didn't think so
she sound is voiced
but oh it is good it is voice but it's
not a continuing like that yeah can't
dog good yeah it is voiced and it has to
be for my example to work out and that's
minus minus minus plus so what we're
interested in is how come one word gets
an S sound and how come the other word
gets the Z sound well it's a pretty
sparse space out there we've already
decided that there are 14,000 possible
phonemes are there only 40 in the
language so that's one thing we can
consider the other way the other thing
that we can think is that well maybe
this is a logical problem like kind of
problem you face for your designing
computer and so Sussman you yep got
stuck for three months thinking about
the problem that way couldn't make any
progress whatsoever and that happens a
lot where you're doing a search you
think you've got a way of approaching it
trying to make it work stay up all night
stay up all night again still can't make
it work
eventually you abandon ship try
something else then they began to say
well let's see all we care about is the
stuff before the two ending sounds we
care about that part of the matrix and
we care about that part of the matrix
and we can ask in what ways are those
things different and they're different
all over the place that's why there are
different words we can ask the question
a little bit differently as we can say
what can we not care about and still
retain enough of a understanding of how
the words are different so as to put the
proper parole or anything on them and
then they worried about that for a long
time I couldn't find a solution to
search space was too big and then they
said maybe what we ought to do is we
ought to think about generalizing this
guy here so that we don't care about it
so now we don't care about that guy and
then he went down on through here saying
well let's see when we can when we have
to stop generalizing because we figure
that we've screwed everything up and we
and the longer keep the Z sound words
separated from the s sound words so that
eventually distilled itself down to the
following algorithm first thing they did
was to collect positive and negative
examples and there there's a positive
example and a negative example that's
not enough to do it right but that's
enough to illustrate the idea so then
the next thing they did was something
that's extremely common in learning
anything and that is to pick a positive
example to start from it's actually not
a bad idea in learning anything to start
with a positive example so they picked a
positive example and they call that a
seed so in our particular case Katz is
going to be our seed and the question
we're going to ask is what are the words
that get pluralized like cat so we've
got a positive and negative example we
picked a seed and now the next step is
to generalize and what I mean by
generalized is you pick some places in
the phoneme mat matrix that you just
don't care about so when you may pick a
positive example you don't care about it
so you change it to an asterisk or as
demonstrated in the program I'm about to
show you a ball or you pick one that's
negative and you turn it to a ball both
so Katz this seed becomes a pattern and
in order to pluralize the word this way
you have to match all the stuff in here
but now what we're going to do is we're
going to gradually turn some of those
elements into don't care symbols until
we get to a point
where we've not cared about so much
stuff that we think that we portal eyes
that one with an S sound to so we keep
generalizing until we cover that is a
saying we admit or match a negative
example so that's how it works
so we generalize like crazy and as soon
as we cover our negative example we quit
otherwise and just go back up here and
generalize some more and now we got to
pick a search technique to decide which
of these guys to actually generalize
when we could pick a we could pick one
at random and they tried that didn't
work but what they decided is that the
thing that influences the pluralization
most is the adjacent phoneme and if that
isn't the thing that does that solves
the problem it will be the one next to
that so in other words the closer you
are the more likely you are to determine
the outcome so these guys over here are
least likely to matter and those are the
ones that are generalized first all
right so if we do that what happens
looks like we're going to come in here
and see that there's a big difference
between the non voice T and the voice 2g
but that's only a guess because I'm
going to show you a fraction of the 14
distinctive features that are involved
so I suppose you'd like to see a
demonstration
so there is our 14 features and that's
our seed they're sitting prominently in
the display with pluses and minuses
indicating the values of the distinctive
features for all three of the phones
involved that funny left bracket isn't a
mistake that's just one convention for
rendering the a sound in cat so it's
pretty hard to tell from just that
matrix what's going to be the
determining feature that separates the
positive examples from the negative
examples you notice that there are
actually two examples down here there's
cat and duck these Ducks got an F sound
ducks yep so dogs and ducks they both
get PluralEyes with an S sound another
hand Beach doesn't that's Beach s dog
we know that's a Z gun guns that's not
in the group so we can run this
experiment no here we go we're
generalizing like crazy
generalizing generalizing generalizing
from left to right so nothing in the
first two columns matters now we get to
the T Wow there it is
so it looks like you PluralEyes with a s
sound the S if and only if you're voiced
you're not voiced can you not stride in
the second-to-the-last in the last in
the last phone of the word that you're
trying to pluralize so that's one
phonological rule that the system has
learned and guess what it's the same
rule that's found in phonological
textbooks so now we can try another
experiment
so this time we're trying to deal with
dog and gun and our negatives are that
what was previously positive plus Beach
was they're still in there as a negative
example let's see how that one works
nothing matters except to the last
column glass phone and now we find out
that if the if the last sound is voiced
then the pluralization gets the Z sound
a voice terminator I'm finally just to
deal with beaches that's peach and it's
funny phonetic spelling
so now it's if the second-to-the-last if
they if the final sound and the word is
striking if it's got this jetty Sound
Beach Beach then it gets the es sound so
let's go back to experiment number one
because I want to point out one small
thing about the way this works you'll
notice that it talks about coverage and
excluded down here in the lower
left-hand corner excluded well they're
three negative examples so they better
all be excluded you don't want to cover
any of the negatives but it says
coverage 2 & 2
that's because it actually is doing and
now we have the vocabulary to say it
quickly it's doing a beam search through
this space so it's not just doing a
depth-first search is doing a beam
search so it's not so as to reduce the
possibility of overlooking a solution so
it says oh the coverage both of the beam
search elements cover both of the of the
of the positive examples and they in
fact have converged to the same solution
so that's how the Sussman and Yip thing
worked and then the next question to ask
is of course why did it work so the
answer as articulated by Sussman and yep
I rather more by Sussman rather more by
Yip and a little bit less by assessment
Yip thinks that it worked because it's a
sparse space and when you have a high
dimensional sparse space it's easy to
put a hyperplane into the space to
separate one set of examples for another
set of examples so let's consider the
following situation suppose we have a
one-dimensional situation and we have
two white examples and we have two
purple examples well too bad for us you
can't separate them now suppose that
this is actually the projection of a two
dimensional space that looks like this
here are the white examples down here
and here are the purple examples up here
now it's easy to see that you can
separate them with a just a line that
goes across like that let's take this
one more step and suppose that this is
actually a projection of a
three-dimensional space that looks like
this this will be dimension 1 this will
be 2 going back there and this will be 3
up here and suppose that the positive
examples are right here on this line
let's say this is a little cube like so
suppose our purple examples are up there
how many ways are there partitioning the
space along those axes well now there's
they're not not even just two of their
three so one way to separate the purple
from the white if she draw a hyperplane
in this case it's just three dimensions
so a plane through here on the on the on
the number three axis you could also put
a plane in on that axis
or you could do both so in one case
you're dividing line would be C on the
first axis would be 1/2 and then don't
care don't hear another solution it
would be don't care and then we divide
on the number 2 axis with a plane up by
1/2 and don't care or we could do it
with 1/2 1/2 and don't care so the
higher the dimension of the space the
easier it is sometimes to put in a plane
that separates the data that's why
sessemann and yep think that we use so
little of possible phoneme space because
it makes the thing learn about that's
one possibility
so one explanation for our of our space
is learner ability there's another
interesting possibility and that is that
if you have a sparse space high
dimensional space with 14 dimensions and
if the 40 points of your language are
spread through evenly throughout that
space now let me say it the other way if
they're placed at random in that space
then according to the central limit
theorem they'll be about equally distant
from each other so it ensures that the
phonemes are highly separable easily
separated when you speak but if you go
to ask a linguist if that's true they
don't know because they're not looking
at it from a computational point of view
well we can look at it from a
computational point of view so I did
that after Sussman you published their
paper and here's the result this is a
diagram that shows all of the phonemes
that are separated by exactly one
distinctive feature so if you look over
in the in this corner here you see that
the constants W and X are separated by
exactly one distinctive feature so
they're not exactly distant from each
other in the space on the other hand
they are pretty easy to separate
relative to the vowels which are up here
in this part of the diagram
which are all tangled up and the valves
are all closed to each other so guess
what
dolls are much harder to separate than
constants not surprisingly because they
often because there are many pairs of
them that are different and only one
distinctive feature alright so now you
back up and you say well gosh that's all
been sort of interesting but what does
it teach us about how to do science and
stuff and what it teaches us is that
this is an example
that's an example which we can use to
illuminate some of the thoughts of David
Marr who I spoke of a previous lecture
connection with vision but here is some
here's Mars Catechism I can't spell very
well so I won't try to resell it but
this is Mars catechism
so what Marsh said is when you're
dealing with an AI problem first thing
to do is to specify the problem gee that
sounds awfully normal the next thing is
to devise the representations suited to
the problem the third thing to do
vocabulary varies but it's something
like determine an approach sometimes I'm
thought of as a method and then for pick
a mechanism or devise an algorithm and
finally five experiment and of course it
never goes linearly like that you start
with a problem and then you go through a
lot of loops up here sometimes even
changing the problem but that's just a
scientific method right start with a
problem and you end up with the
experiment but that's not what people in
AI over the bulk of its existence have
tended to do what they tended to do is
to fall in love with particular
mechanisms and and then they attempt to
apply those mechanisms to every problem
so you might say well gee neural nets
are so cool I think all of human
intelligence can be explained with
suitable neural net and that's that's
not the right way to do it
so that's mechanism Envy you fall in
love with the mechanism you try to apply
it where it isn't the right thing
this is an example of starting with a
problem and bringing to the problem the
right representations gosh distinctive
features once we've got the right
representation then the constraints
emerge which enable us to devise an
approach write an algorithm and do an
experiment as they did so the Sussman
lip thing is an example of doing AI
stuff in a way that's congruent with
Martha's catechism which I highly
recommend they could have come in here
and said well we're devotees of the idea
of neural nets let's see if we can make
a machine that will properly pull-up
Lorelei's words using a neural net
that's oh that's a loser because it
doesn't match the problem to the
mechanism it tries to force fit them the
mechanism into some procrustean bed
where it doesn't actually work very well
so what this leaves open of course is a
question of oh well what is a good
representation and here's the other half
of mark's catechism characteristic
number one is that it makes the right
things explicit so in this particular
case it makes distinctive features
explicitly another thing that maher was
noted for with stereo vision so in that
particular world discontinuities in the
image when you go across an edge with
the things that were made explicit once
you've got a representation it makes the
right things explicit you can say
there's also expose constraint
and if you have a representation and
exposes constraint you're off and
running because it's constraint that you
need in order to do the processing that
leads to a solution so don't have the
right representation if it doesn't
expose constraints now you're not gonna
be able to make a very good model out of
it and finally there was a kind of
localness criteria if you have a
representation in which you can see the
right answer by looking at descriptions
through a soda straw that's probably a
better representation that one that's
all spread out it's true with programs
right if you can see how they work by
looking through a soda straw you're much
better situation to understand something
if you have to look out here and there
on the next page and in the next five so
all this is basically common sense but
this is a kind of common sense that
makes you smarter as an engineering
scientist especially as a scientist
because if you go into a problem with
mechanism env you're apt to study
mechanisms in a naive way and never
reach a solution that will be
satisfactory
you